tja was passiert denn dann kann es
überhaupt aus ihren augen so weit kommen
dass eventuell sophie polizeibeamte in
quarantäne müssen oder erkranken dass
man das ganze system nicht richtig
aufrechterhalten kann sind sie dafür
gewappnet ich bin davon überzeugt dass
das nicht so ist die polizei ist auch
nicht müde sondern hellwach und zwar
seit langem und sie ist ja auch nicht
neu mit dieser konnte situation
konfrontiert ich halte überhaupt nichts
davon ja auch nur den eindruck zu
erwecken dass die polizei irgendwo
flächendeckend nicht einsatzbereit wäre
ganz im gegenteil es gibt viele pläne
liegen alle in der schublade sind im
übrigen seit jahrzehnten erprobt da wird
auch nichts neues konzipiert sondern die
polizei kann aus dem stand heraus auch
auf krisen auf der situation reagieren
hat sie übrigens im letzten winter ja
auch gemacht aber vor jahrzehnten gab es
noch keine omikron variante und im
letzten winter auch noch nicht helfen
was passiert denn wenn beispielsweise
eine ganze polizeiwache oder eine ganze
hundertschaft in quarantäne muss genau
das was im letzten winter auch passiert
ist das hat es übrigens gegeben als
hunderte und tausende kolleginnen und
kollegen in quarantäne waren und
erkrankt sind dann werden reserven
gebildeten reserven mobilisiert und es
wird unterstützung angefordert es gibt
ein seit jahrzehnten erprobtes system
der gegenseitigen unterstützung der
bundesländer gemeinsam mit der
bundespolizei übrigens und das passiert
sehr schnell da müssen wir nichts neu
auflegen das ist seit jahrzehnten
erprobt denn es hat ja immer wieder
große einsätze auch länderübergreifende
einsätze gegeben die den einsatz von
tausenden polizistinnen und polizisten
aus anderen ländern erforderlich machen
und so etwas kann man aber das szenario
erwähnt ist ja dass überall gleichzeitig
dieses virus zu schlagen könnte dann
können sie eben nicht aus niedersachsen
jemand nach nordrhein-westfalen abziehen
oder umgekehrt der bundeskanzler hat der
die polizei aufgefordert die pandemie
pläne zu überarbeiten was müssen sie da
überarbeiten wie müssen sie sich
organisieren es hat diese aufforderung
nicht bedurft denn diese pläne gibt es
in den ländern das weiß der
bundeskanzler vielleicht nicht aber die
länder ministerpräsidenten hätten es
ihnen sagen können man kann
beispielsweise
kurorten bilden so dass das pandemie
risiko dass das infektionsrisiko für die
einsatzkräfte eingegrenzt wird aus acht
stunden schichten werden zwölf stunden
schichten es werden andere prioritäten
gesetzt dh
dinge die jetzt nicht unbedingt gemacht
werden müssen bleiben dann liegen weil
natürlich in einer solchen situation die
pandemie bekämpfung absolute priorität
das heißt alle diese maßnahmen liegen in
der schublade die können mobilisiert
werden im übrigen wir haben schon in
nordrhein westfalen zum karneval sogar
einsatzkräfte eingesetzt die aus der
ausbildung gekommen sind und auch da ist
die welt nicht zusammengebrochen es kann
auf jeden fall jeder damit rechnen die
polizei ist da wenn man sie braucht und
es sollte niemand glauben es könnte
beispielsweise in der silvesternacht
oder anderswo große partys feiern weil
die polizei jetzt nicht einsatzfähig
wäre genau das könnte ein teurer irrtum
werden denn dann kommt die polizei unter
nagel des bußgelder und zwar sei das ist
die ankündigung sie fühlen sich also
gerüstet dann sehen auch keinen bedarf
da noch einmal nachzubessern wie es ja
durchaus auch gefordert wurde wie
blicken sie jetzt auf diese silvester
nächte und finden sie eigentlich dass
das ganze eher eine art panikmache ist
wenn aus ihren augen gibt es ja
überhaupt keinen grund noch einmal
irgendetwas zu erarbeiten sie sagen wir
sind gerüstet da muss jetzt nicht mehr
viel gemacht werden also jetzt zeigt
sich natürlich einerseits auch das 1 1
schwach aufgestellt der start der
schwache schwache strukturen hat jetzt
tatsächlich nur noch steuerbar ist in
dem die beschäftigten selber das machen
und ein unglaubliches engagement an den
tag legen notfalls auch mehrere
schichten hintereinander machen bis an
den rand der erschöpfung das ist in der
vergangenheit immer passiert aber es
muss uns auch eine mahnung sein für die
zukunft wenn es um personalplanungen
geht das heißt wir brauchen tatsächlich
einen starken staat der auch ich sag
jetzt mal auf solche krisenhaften
situation schnell reagiert aber angst
ist nicht nur keine strategie sondern
auch der schlechteste ratgeber den wir
in dieser situation haben können sagt er
rainer wendt vorsitzender der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft